salut comme le nom de la chaîne lundi
que je m'appelle fabian licka et je suis
mentaliste alors techniquement ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que des fois je
suis sur scène un spectacle que d'autres
fois j'écris des livres sur ce sujet
mais que la majeure partie de mon temps
je la passe sur youtube à vous faire des
vidéos soit pour essayer de vous bluffer
en bluffant d'autres personnes ou alors
on vous explique en des choses et en
vous donnant des astuces de mentalisme
mais d'une manière générale l'idée c'est
de se marrer de faire des trucs fun et
qui est toujours un rapport plus ou
moins lointain avec le cerveau voilà
cela c'est ce que j'ai essayé de faire
et abonnez vous
[Musique]